[Aplausos]
mulheres são mais sensíveis homens são
mais racionais crianças não entendem
conversa de adultos índios devem ser
tutelados negros têm mais facilidade
para o esporte e para a música mulheres
sempre puxa o tapete umas das outras e o
sol gira ao redor da terra
um dia alguém ousou duvidar dessa última
informação pobre coitado louco herege e
hoje todos sabemos que a terra gira ao
redor do sol
e porque todas as outras afirmações que
não tem embasamento científico nenhum
continuam a ocupar o lugar de verdades
porque vivemos certeza sim fundadas sem
questioná las em alguns momentos da vida
em que buscamos muito respostas ea gente
não encontra esse momento é uma ótima
oportunidade para darmos um passo a trás
e vermos onde todas essas respostas
prontas estão nos levando o site de
busca não me responde como eu faço para
que meu marido entenda que as tarefas de
casa devem ser igualmente divididas já
que chegamos igualmente cansados do
trabalho as tarefas que ele trás do
serviço são feitas enquanto eu cuido das
crianças e preparar a janta e o que eu
trago do escritório é feito de madrugada
enquanto todos inclusive ele dorme e no
dia seguinte ele chega revigorado no
escritório e eu cansada
mas isso em vez de buscarmos respostas a
gente começar a buscar questões e se eu
simplesmente não der como certo aquele
padrão de comportamento que eu não faz
mais sentido para mim e se eu usar
querer igualdade a gente questionar as
coisas do dia a dia é o primeiro passo
para que a gente escolha como queremos
que seja o nosso modo de pensar
vocês já pensaram se os privilegiados
entendessem que só existe esse planeta
para vivermos e que cada privilégio cria
uma desigualdade e que nessa roda a
conta em dia vem a gente pode abalar o
estabelecido através de questionamentos
essa relativização pode levar gente a
abrir espaço para um novo cotidiano para
uma nova vida e isso cria fissuras
fissuras nas certezas dessas fissuras
pode nascer aquela plantinha existentes
essa mistura tem o nome de liberdade e
como podemos saber que a liberdade está
sendo alcançada através dessas questões
simplesmente não sabemos provocou a
única curiosidade que vale a pena ser
perseguida com um pouco de obstinação
não é aquela que visa assimilar
conhecimentos mas aquela que separa a
gente da gente mesmo aquela que produz
um desse caminho aquele que conhece
não sabemos se estamos na direção
correta porque não existe direção
correta
o que existem são certezas da rosas e
questões libertadoras você já conheceram
aquela pessoa que uma roda de conversa
só ela está certa que ela só fala fala
fala e quando
outra pessoa vai falar ao invés de ouvir
e só está esperando o momento para falar
novamente por outro lado você já
conheceram aquela pessoa que com a minha
mãe se ouve com muita atenção às
questões que você fica pensando por um
mês pra minha mãe quando você está na
frente dela só existe em você
e parece que o mundo para o nome disso é
a abertura
essa abertura possibilita a gente
enxergar nós mesmos
enxergamos o outro e esse outro pode ser
uma pessoa um animal uma planta uma obra
de arte
qualquer coisa que simplesmente exista
enxergar o outro salva vidas e como a
gente pode fazer depois depois o que a
gente pode fazer depois desse abalo
depois de criar suas fissuras existe aí
para a gente falou eu não posso falar
agora é ninguém três minutos está
obrigada bom crianças
as crianças têm uma capacidade de
imaginar possibilidades para os objetos
gigantesca uma blusa pode ser um bebê um
controle remoto uma barra de chocolate e
um sapato um telefone mas essa
criatividade vai sendo podado ao longo
do tempo para que a gente faça as coisas
como devem ser feitas e para que a gente
use as coisas como devem ser usadas
vocês já pensaram o que seria da nossa
vida hoje
se os inventores tivessem obedecido a
isso
é ser inventivo implica em ter uma dose
de desobediência em querer testar as
possibilidades por si mesmo para tirar
as próprias conclusões ser inventivo é
habitar a fissura da liberdade abalar as
certezas e expandir as possibilidades
todos nós queremos um mundo melhor
temos como dever pensar como poderia ser
diferente
todos podemos ser inventivos e pra isso
além de exercitar a criatividade é
preciso encontrar um algo que realmente
gosta de fazer para que você mergulha
nesse campo e não se sinta cansado ea
sua criatividade floresça mais mais esse
campo é o seu campo de inventividade é
como a sua subjetividade vai se
comunicar com o mundo para essa tarefa
a gente pode se inspirar em pensadores e
cientistas músicos e artesãos
qualquer pessoa que vocês conheçam que
tenha um fluxo próprio e consiga
comunicar isso para o mundo ao invés de
seguir o fluxo por isso eu vos convido a
entrar na cabine de controle e tirar o
seu pensamento do piloto automático
boas questões e obrigada
[Aplausos]